you'll have seen the videos on YouTube
with stabilization that kind of gliding
through the matrix effect that takes out
camera shaking but how's it work well to
explain that means your back a little
bit to how it used to work
the naive approach to doing camera
stabilization see the early way to do it
you know back when computer a reasonable
amount of processing power was to pick
some object somewhere in the background
that was fairly bright lock onto it and
then just keep that in exactly the same
place no matter how much the camera move
gives a bit of shake map there we go
then if you want to add a bit of
rotation and scaling to that you lock
onto a second thing on the other side of
frame track both of them draw a line and
keep that line Rocksteady
as things rotate there we go and that's
okay if your shot is static but if your
shot is starting to move then you might
have a bit of a problem because you have
nothing in the background to lock onto
for the entire shot you have me but even
lock onto my face it starts to look very
weird indeed and then you start using a
new truck what you'll find in iMovie and
in older versions of premiere and things
like that which is you look at the
entire frame you work out where
everything is going every pixel what has
changed from one frame to the next and
then you assume the big movement the big
background movement in there that is how
the camera has jumped and you try and
reduce that over time you zoom in a bit
your crop of it you rotate a bit and you
try to minimize that which works okay
with old-school
cameras but nowadays modern cameras like
this have something called a rolling
shutter which means which means that the
top of the frame is a fraction hundreds
of a second ahead of the bottom of the
frame and that screws up all kinds of
computer vision algorithms so you need
to deal with that and nowadays the
modern version the latest version of cs6
and I'm moving things like that use what
Adobe call subspace warp the ability to
stretch and twist different types of the
frame different parts of the frame in
different ways as it goes up kind of
merging and melding the whole thing
what causes that kind of driving
obviously because if I put out my hand
towards and you move the camera up and
down slightly different parts of me are
visible from behind that ultimately you
can't know what the pixels should have
be okay but still one away because
YouTube has a bit of a strange effect
they have a kind of timing thing
that's down to a paper that they
released and put online it's a one of
the computer vision conferences trying
to work out how to do its cinematic
stabilisation so what they do hold the
camera steady Matt where's old
stabilization would have just you know
let's try to ease that try to make that
as simple as possible nowadays but it
tries to turn it into a camera move
YouTube will start a camera shot and
stop it start camera shot and stopping
they will try and work out a 3d solution
for everything that's going on that's
the most modern technology they've got
but give it a few years there might be
something better because right now what
you have are films where all 2d movies
have been updated to 3d which means that
they are essentially extrapolating where
a camera would have been if you can
apply that to stabilization if you could
work out what would happen if I kept my
hand there and the camera happened to be
where it should have been well then you
have a much better stabilization
technology then you have something that
could reduce Steadicam shots out of
nowhere we're not there yet light field
cameras they're coming in might be able
to help with that but in the meantime
well YouTube stabilization is the best
we've got that is more or less
mathematically how it works and that is
something you might not have know
the big sign over that says duck white
thank you buck
you